foreign
welcome to Harry Potter Theory Lord
Voldemort and gallet Grindelwald are the
two most powerful dark wizards of modern
history and their lives were eerily
similar both of them shared a common foe
a Helper stumbledore and both of them
shamelessly butchered their fellow
Wizards and witches in pursuit of power
but when you look at the pair of dark
Wizards you might be surprised to find
out that there's quite a bit that
separates them from their individual
manifestos to their actual magical
powers Voldemort and Grindelwald
couldn't have been more different today
we're going to shed some light on those
differences and find out what divided
these two wizards 9. Voldemort's Elona
to put it simply Lord Voldemort is a
loner noun that obviously doesn't mean
he was technically alone all the time
from the first day attended Hogwarts
School of Witchcraft and Wizardry Tom
Riddle demonstrated his remarkable
Charisma and cultivated a cult that
followed him around from class to class
but those students many of whom would
evolve into murderous Death Eaters were
simply followers Voldemort ever
considered them his peers and certainly
not his friends and it makes sense if
you think about it Lord voldel was
conceived while his father was Bewitched
by a love potion according to law The
Offspring of such unions were incapable
of love and if they ever reached
adulthood could be considered sociopaths
by contrast much of galic grindelwald's
early life was defined by love and
passion his partnership with Albus
Dumbledore is what drove Grindelwald to
pursue the Hallows and pushed for the
end of the magical laws that restricted
Wizards and witches even after all of
his fights when Grindelwald was over 100
years in age he likely looked back at
his life with regrets and probably
wished he could have done it all
differently 8. Threat Level after seeing
the vicious battles at Harry Potter and
his friends endured it's hard to imagine
that Voldemort was anything less than a
global threat
but if you actually look at the details
of the Death Eaters and their campaigns
the group limited their activities to
Great Britain for the most part
Voldemort was interested in overthrowing
the ministry of magic and revamping The
Wizarding World in the UK he probably
had greater interests and wanted to
waltz into France and Continental Europe
after securing England but during the
events of the Harry Potter books
Voldemort was firmly fixed in the
British Isles and when we compare this
to Grindelwald we'll see that Tom
Riddle's Campaign Of Terror seems far
smaller by comparison Grindelwald
Revolution stretched across the globe
from the shores of the United States to
the streets of the French Capital
Gellert wanted to overthrow the
international Wizarding order and so he
staged a multi-front campaign to do so
7. their reign during the second
Wizarding War Lord Voldemort managed to
claim power for just about a year during
that time Harry Potter Ron Weasley and
Hermione Granger tried to finish what
Albus Dumbledore had started hunting and
destroying all the remaining horcruxes
at times it seemed like the three
Hogwarts students would never find the
evil relics that held blood Voldemort's
soul but in the end they succeeded after
only a few months Voldemort was not only
overthrown but he was killed Voldemort's
single year of rule paled in comparison
to Grindelwald although Voldemort
controlled the ministry during his Reign
might have been stronger Grindelwald and
his acolytes were active for over two
decades during that time the dark wizard
LED political and Guerrilla campaigns
against his fellow Wizards unlike the
Death Eaters who only represented a
small affluent group of pure blood
families within Britain grindelwald's
followers were far more vast gallet was
almost like a political party of his own
with thousands of supporters around the
globe 6. who was more evil to be honest
most Wizards would admit that Lord
Voldemort was just about the most evil
sorcerer in existence when Hagrid
Dumbledore or any number of Harry's
mentors talked about Voldemort they
often claimed that he was more than just
simply evil as if there were no words
that could describe the depravity that
Tom Riddle had reached even though galic
Grindelwald was No Angel by any stretch
of the imagination the crimes he
committed were reasonable by comparison
grindelwald's goals after all were once
shared by Albus Dumbledore and they were
far more political than Voldemort's own
selfish desires Grindelwald wanted to
free The Wizarding World from the rules
that kept them hidden he believed that
the Wizarding World should be the most
powerful Society on the planet and that
Muggles and their own governments should
exist beneath them while on the surface
that sounds like something Voldemort
would agree with Tom Riddle's methods
were far more Craven he never showed
compassion and would never have
displayed regret as Grindelwald seemed
to do at the end of his life 5. horcrux
versus Hallows one of the biggest
differences between these two dark
Wizards was the way they sought power
both were obsessed with increasing their
magical abilities and both set out on
quest to gather the Deathly Hallows but
Grindelwald limited himself to those
magical relics and eventually became the
second most powerful owner of the Elder
Wand that hallow which Voldemort
desperately tried to claim for himself
would be the Dark Lord's undoing when he
tried to use it to kill Harry Potter but
unlike Voldemort Grindelwald didn't dare
undergo the complex procedure to split
his soul and create horcruxes and if you
think about why there's really only a
handful of answers some historians might
suggest that Grindelwald simply didn't
possess the knowledge to create these
dark enchantments but considering that
galactron the world's magical abilities
and expertise was only narrowly
surpassed by Albert Dumbledore this
historical take seems pretty unlikely in
this case the more obvious case appears
to be true Grindelwald didn't create
horcruxes because he didn't want to
perhaps he simply wasn't evil enough to
even consider the selfish murder of
another person in order to split his
soul or maybe he thought he'd be more
powerful without horcruxes although
there could be another reason 4.
attitude towards death compared to
Voldemort Grindelwald showed almost no
fear of death this might be another
reason why the famed dark Wizard never
created horcruxes of his own when Tom
Riddle stared into a bogart the magical
creature that showed you your own
greatest fear the dark wizard was
shocked to find his own corpse he didn't
see a massive spider like Ron Weasley or
the death of a loved one like Apple's
Dumbledore no Voldemort saw his own
demise in the Bogut Lord Voldemort split
his soul seven times and sought to
master the dark arts because he feared
his own death and Grindelwald didn't by
the end of his life when Lord snotkin
news jail cell Grindelwald laughed in
the younger Dark Lord's face and
encouraged riddle to kill him although
Grindelwald was well over 100 years in
age by that time so he might have
welcomed the idea of passing still it's
hard to imagine Lord Voldemort ever
achieving such a state of Zen when it
comes to his own mortality 3. schooling
it might shock you to know that garlic
Grindelwald and the famed co-founder of
Hogwarts salazaren bear no relation at
all throughout the medieval and modern
eras many of the most terrifying dark
Wizards passed through the Slytherin
house at Hogwarts School of Witchcraft
and Wizardry in fact it's almost hard to
imagine a dark Wizard or witch could
exist without first having been sorted
into Southern first but not only was
Grindelwald never enrolled in Hogwarts
he attended a completely different
School The durmstrang Institute a place
he was later expelled from for
performing twisted and dark experiments
on fellow students
2. parcel tongue speaking to serpents is
almost a prerequisite when it comes to
being a dark wizard but unlike herpa the
fowl and Lord Voldemort gelat
Grindelwald never showed an ability for
parcel tongue that skill which was such
an heirloom for The Heirs of Southern
was only one of a few that Grindelwald
never managed to master although
considering how much the dark wizard
achieved his inability to converse with
snakes wasn't that big of a deal 1.
dueling do you think galic Grindelwald
was a better duelist than Lord Voldemort
that might seem like a foolish question
to ask especially when you recall the
exact circumstances of grindelwald's
death he was executed by Lord Voldemort
after all but that wasn't really a fair
Showdown gallet was at least 115 years
old at the time and he was completely
unarmed although Wizards and witches
lived unusually long lives Grindelwald
was still several decades past his prime
when we compared Lord Voldemort's own
dueling achievements against those of a
prime gallet it's surprising to see just
how much Grindelwald shines by
comparison both of these dark Wizards
shared Albus Dumbledore as an adversary
but Voldemort never seemed to get the
better of the Hogwarts Headmaster
Grindelwald on the other hand nearly
defeated him during their famous Jewel
at the end of the second world war of
course there were reasons for
Voldemort's losses as well as
grindelwald's near win still most
magical historians would favor
Grindelwald in this comparison if you
want a greater breakdown of who is the
more powerful wizard go and check out my
video Voldemort vs Grindelwald who is
more powerful Link in the description
and there you have it nine ways in which
Lord Voldemort in garlic Grindelwald are
different what do you think how do you
think they're different let me know in
the comments below until next time
remember when we allow ourselves to be
consumed by anger the only victim is
ourself
[Music]